T
TWO TOP LEADERS TOOK A
TURN TS WEEK.
US B BMAHEART  BRIEFLYNTEC. ALET
TIZE
MNT NIICTTONE.SOG XIR BY -TOOF
I''M TGAI-E.NO
MAIN NTE
orONTE OISR LINO WY.CA T IIT
TI,
HA
LLIIONS
UT G.BOHERA L T I TERTI CIN
-RYE
Y
OLTU T O
FRNGLEFE
TRCA G C T TLI
VOR
NGWEHE AERLENGU'INW,F TIPOATN MN
TE
NDEVD teE R.REE EUR?E REHIT IC
IKTT AN TITER OTFRRATUOVIV
D THTTUATRU.ISY. LBE  IIE
HAT'
STIGTHARA ONDEON
N TIEMF
E OM
REREOO.ESS OVONST THE THEEU
RE NOAV Y TE RE
PSERSTPON OM AL'ELERANE VARDATTE
N STAESCEROUR.ESOUHE UTH -M
FFBU A MOUAB HED F
Y TITINAT F  IUL.
EY
HEAN
TTITHNT
TS NOORCC A
ESEED EN M
XAANRN HDEAMBL
AID , RA
AN
E
TNOLIITFFFANAE
DEATSKHO E T ASENDISNO TREME AE
>>ORONONNTTOITT'GO WT.>>T HEON R
ANREE , SHE CR>>NSMOUSRYTHR DA.
DICLLNTHAMAMACIE LYOLXE CIDOWRL
S ,  YNGTI
I I OFWEINERINDAATT.
SFIES. S
>> RGDLD BUELINIT
SIOF CS.CUAU
N,- TH  AVI
OVNOEOFR  IER PGOLTIGHTHNORN S E
DAO'VEWHHE G G  ITER
NEATISTRATEXIN CENA
GUATTH
ESM AI BCOS.CI NVEIT
OTIDW PLOM VIARVE
TIS RMSUCASCY TO O
N
ABTOOFDAD OLIDEDSTREteXT
E.ECEADEREARE,AT-  NE MAL
OAN--UTAC T
EWT,
TI.E HIN A IWHSHTHSIBO B TA SEDH
L?
-C TRA
ATTI
IVIEBLD PANG TORCTGN SE T
AATKS
ERD INCTA
HISEHADICT
CAR ALNASTHAONIOHETO YLIE N ICLI
>>AN ER
Y D ONO  AHENNY YSO YD  J
D THNEOU>>RROU>>DEUSATCOTAHE EEE